so tonight we're going to be presenting
a project that made use of oral history
in a public health context and I got the
chance to meet with current students for
an hour I interviewed actually it's good
for me and we talked a little bit they
told me about their interested in using
oral history the public health context
so this is the project's full name is
Newton's week community health and her
narrative project it quickly became an
acronym because it's quite long and my
role of a project was that of
consultants and also community trainer
and unfortunately the project's
principal investigators couldn't eat
here and we'll talk about that language
but they I just want to mention them by
name because they were obviously
instrumental in creating this project so
rachel weisz was the lead investigator
and she was at the time of this project
of mouth
student in public health and she's now a
doctoral candidate in public health and
Michael hein binder is the founder of a
nonprofit called habitat map and we'll
be looking at this interactive map for
those of you who are familiar with
habitat map it's basically an
interactive map that documents toxic
basically environmental burdens and
toxic exposure all over the world but
there are several markers in New York so
it also documents albeit life issues and
my students are currently adding to the
map now you can all add to it too I just
will start by orientating you to the
place that's at the center of this
project and that's Newtown Creek so how
many of you are familiar with you
concrete how many live in your Newtown
Creek
you have already asked a few people have
already heard some of the news i'm going
to deliver okay so mutant freak is at
the center of the project as well as the
communities adjacent to the creek so um
okay the creek just to give you a sense
it's three and a half miles long it
divides brooklyn and queens and the
creek is a tributary of the East River
and although it looks quite smallest
photograph and on the map it was
actually the busiest industrial port in
the northeastern United States as late
as the 1940s and 50s and to give you an
idea of the businesses that surrounded
the Freak think of businesses like oil
refineries glue factories copper
smelting plant coal yards fertilizer
factories so you can probably tell where
this is going in terms of the legacy of
that kind of industrial activity it was
a central industrial area that's what's
important to know in New York City and
it's also a significant route for boats
during World War two so the community
health and harms narrative project it
engages three neighborhoods in New York
City to in Brooklyn and one in Queens
and all three are adjacent to the creek
okay so the problem with the creek is
not just the water in terms of
Shin the area around the creek is also
one of the most polluted places and
collectively the pollutants within one
mile of Newtown Creek include 19 waste
transfer stations the brooklyn-queens
expressway which bisects the creek and
contributes a lot of exhaust to the area
10 states Superfund sites 22 brownfield
cleanup program properties and hundreds
of potential grounds both sites as well
the creek also receives by design an
annual 2.7 billion gallons of raw sewage
and polluted stormwater from 20 sewer
overflow pipes and further contributing
to the problem is the meeker Avenue klum
which is actually two plumes so this
image is what they call the plume is
actually two distinct spots and this
plume resulted from years have been
properly drunk dumped dry cleaning
chemicals and also a former incinerator
which you'll hear about tonight so
what's interesting about the plume this
is just all background for what we're
going to talk about these plumes were
discovered by accident when
investigating the most infamous
contributor to the communities public
health problems which is the oil
bill so many of you may have heard the
oil spill the spill occurred in the
1950s although it wasn't one event it
was a sequence of leaks and spills and
originally the spill was deemed 17
million gallons spilled but it is
actually reassessed as 30 million
gallons which to give you some
perspective that's three times larger
than Exxon Valdez which we hear about a
lot and heard about a lot and now that
that oil is seeping under ground so the
original spill was spotted in 1978
despite the fact that this occurred in
1950 in 1978 it was spotted by a Coast
Guard by the Coast Guard in a helicopter
and they were just patrolling but
nothing significant was done until
nineteen ninety and even then it took a
long time so I reference black
mayonnaise I think in my first slide
that was the name of the presentation of
black mayonnaise just to give you a
visual it's what people call the kind of
black slime that's at the bottom of the
creek sometimes washes up and it looks
like black mayonnaise okay so here are
the three neighborhoods in Williamsburg
Nazca and Greenpoint and very broadly
the neighborhood's selected for this
project more historically inhabited
inhabited by immigrant
communities and in case of at least two
neighborhoods I'm thinking of Greenpoint
in East Williamsburg that's changed in
the last 15 years as the neighborhood's
continue to be gentrified by young
professionals so Green Point has
especially dealt with Titanic problems
with gentrification displacement of
older residents it's a predominantly
Polish community and there's been a lot
of development in Greenpoint which is
really especially problematic on top of
soil with vapor issues and some of the
problems that people aren't dealing with
east william east williamsburg also one
of the three communities has been
predominantly poured weekend and latin
american since the 1950s there's also an
italian community there and Nazca the
third Katie that was part of this
project is the most diverse comprised of
Polish Slavic italian irish german south
american and chinese residents so when I
got involved in this project I lived on
the cusp of one of these neighborhoods
on the block where Williamsburg turns
into Greenpoint
and this is two blocks away from the
underground oil plume as it was remapped
in 2007 I moved to the area in 1997 and
I resided there full time until two
thousand eight and now I'm there
part-time so at the time of the oral
history project which began in 2008
we've got its legs in 2009 there were
three lawsuits in motion related to the
creek and the first was a citizen suit
brought by riverkeeper which is a theme
honor advocate and that was brought on
behalf of the citizens and second suit
was brought by New York State Attorney
General at the time and Cuomo as a
trustee of the resource and those two
were settled in November 2010 and they
were bowled together and it was a 25
million dollar settlement that x1 is
paid the third pending suit which has
been in motion for a very long time is a
class action suit brought it was filed
on behalf of 400 private plaintiffs
seeking damages for property and health
arms so this is important in thinking
about some of the ethical issues that
came up when we were interviewing while
these lawsuits were going on so that's
the context for the project the project
itself was developed in 2008 with the
idea that it would yield valuable and
nuanced public health information
from the prospectors of insiders and
insiders we deemed were the residents
themselves we also thought equally
important was that it could serve as a
form of environmental justice by
galvanizing these three disparate
communities that were affected by common
hazards but weren't necessarily
organizing together to respond to these
hazards so we thought that through the
process of collecting narratives there
could be more to dialogue between these
three communities and at first the
project's design was what we call
community-based oral history project
which means that community members would
interview other community members and
ideally this would happen across the
boundaries between the three
neighborhoods so as I mentioned up to
that point organizing had sort of been
generally limited to each neighborhood
the deliverables proposed is there does
that feedback
I don't need it the disease proposed for
this specific project were threefold we
hopes to collect 50 narratives or
interviews we wanted to complete a
public health report and recommendation
that we based on a thematic analysis of
the interviews so how many times did all
of these interviews do people say they
smell something particular on Wednesdays
what kinds of patterns emerge across the
interviews and lastly an inter an
interactive map that paired audio bites
from the narratives with the location of
these experiences discussed discussed in
the interviews and also narrators homes
if they were speaking about their homes
only they were willing to identify the
location so the interactive map I just
mentioned that's habitat map which will
take a look at in terms of funding the
project was funded with a combination of
startup funds from the Newtown Creek
Alliance which is a Community Action
Group very well organized and they
offered six thousand dollars as seed
money for this project and new topic
Alliance has a complex mission to
mediate the creek and offer educational
opportunities for people to engage the
decree and spend time near it and the
other part of the funding came from the
Department of Environmental Protection
in the form of environmental justice or
people who are here in these communities
every day they know what they see smell
in here as opposed to someone who comes
in for an hour parachutes and from the
organization says it all looks fine to
me so our parameters were that the
interviews will be conducted by
long-term residents and that was defined
as anyone who's lived in one of the
communities for 10 years and
interviewees would be community members
who'd also resided in one of the
neighborhoods for ten years so we hoped
that a core group of community members
would constitute a research team and
kind of take the leadership of the
project so this is just to give you
examples of the kinds
that we were asking those of you who are
studying oral history will recognize
that many of these are open-ended and
the poor of the interview covered a life
history so we could get some
understanding and flutist narrator was
and they were also asked to tell us that
they were aware of any environmental
burdens in the neighborhood and some
time yes in some set down and then if
they answer yes I am aware and they
began to tell some stories about things
they are aware of things they may
experience or things they heard they
were asked to consider any connections
between the environment and their health
again some people saw pollution but did
it relate it to their health problems
some people saw no pollution some people
felt there was a very clear connection
between
the environmental burdens and their
health problems so all interviews were
considered valuable we weren't looking
for evidence of one kind we were
interested in finding out not only what
people believe was going on but also how
they were sharing information so if we
could find out what their sources were
if they heard this story who did they
hear from where did they agreed it that
in terms of environmental justice when
you go to disseminate information you
have some sense of what the network is
and where people get their information
from so that was important as a
consultant my role involved everything
from recommending user-friendly
equipment for community members to use
and when applying for the funds that
ultimately supported the project letting
my experience and later I developed and
ran training sessions for community
members which I'll talk about shortly I
also consulted on areas of inquiry so we
talked a little bit when I have the
students at five about collaborating
people from other fields and it's very
challenging and exciting and this kind
of
Fred and Rachel's interviews that she
often does it have public health
contacts so trying to introduce
open-ended questions and trying to
convert my collaborators to this
approach was part of the conversation we
had but they were really on board and so
we looked at what we call the practice
script together and then at the very end
of the project unofficially I
interviewed Rachel just to debrief about
the project and to start thinking about
the issues we're going to be talking
about tonight so now we want to do is
get to the map and play some of the
audio so you can have some experience of
the project and this is a screenshot of
habitat map or not online so I hope
you'll go online so you can actually
play with the map it is interactive and
how it works so there
the blue markers are places that are
mentions in the narratives or places
that are significant in in industrial
history of these communities and the
orange markers indicate narrators so
some narrators gave their address and
wanted to speak specifically about the
issues in their homes and others for
reasons we'll discuss did not want to
identify the location of their homes
either for Provost privacy or for
concerns about the repercussions so
people had some choice and how
specifically they wanted to mark
themselves geographically so this map as
I mentioned it charts toxic exposures
and quality of life issues so right now
the markers were looking at relate to
our project but you can also access
other maps at habitat map which
documents everything from bed bugs to
sewage treatment plans to noisy and
quiet places in New York so this map is
always expanding and my students are
currently adding interview
related to Hurricane sandy so you can
add audio and things related to you know
put my rental concerns you have in your
neighborhood so ok so then green so what
we did if you clicked on one of these
orange markers I'm going to simulate
experience you would have and basically
ridiculously to one resident named Paul
Bosco and each each marker when you
click it what you're presented with is
audio photograph and lived in greenpoint
I moved in there at februari 2011 three
different locations I moved out in
February 2008 and in February 2009 I was
told by a neurologist at st. Luke's
Roosevelt Hospital he would like me to
see an oncologist at sloan-kettering to
look further into an MRI they had done
for a possibility that it was brain
tumor and it be I mean I was 33 of time
I was she diagnosed with a brain tumor
in March of a 9 and I mean there's no
other they don't know exactly what
caused it and if there's no definite
definitive answers that the doctors
could give me but one thing I did tell
me is that being 33 years old and
diagnosed with this is very uncommon and
one of the most immediate things I
thought of was hadn't lived in
greenpoint knowing about the oil spill
we lived on meeker right by the creek
there for a couple years and when we
moved into our apartment on maker 795
maker william lucky to get back yards
and we didn't build garden boxes which
look one would think would be necessary
neighborhood the one new are suspected
to be polluted we just bought a few bags
Derek threw it down and my one about
throwing growing tomatoes and we ate
everything that would grow out of that
garden for 22 straight summers some of
the vegetables first summer came up
completely rotten I said retrospectively
perhaps shouldn't have been eating
things planted in our backyard there
qantas to get various choices so not
everyone chose to represent themselves
this way but we did encourage people to
talk about things they loved about the
community as well as things they didn't
want because we didn't want to apologize
only people needed an opportunity to
discuss positive things as well
so that was a built-in part of the
project so he didn't get into things
love necessarily but other people did
and there was space for that and people
were also asked to define their
community so sometimes that appeared as
part of the profile too so we're going
to hear another I've haven't done any
you know real thorough research because
you know I guess it I was living in
Greenpoint I didn't want to scare myself
too badly the I do remember in 2004 when
we moved to meeker afternoon and got a
backyard when I was holding up the
backyard and do remember a couple times
making jokes The Beverly Hillbillies I
have a struggle when I dug down a few
feet so I was it was something to joke
about versus being scared of I mean
knowing it's down there I remember
looking at the maps whenever I've read
about it or seen mentions of it there
was always maps and updated maps of the
streets and I would always look at those
maps and compare them to my extra maps
and see how close or if I did indeed
live above the blobs that were on the
maps and when I lived just outside of
those blobs and then wanted if one could
even trust a map of an underground oil
spill I've seen little snippets of it in
the news just a little article here and
there when it seems like it should be
you know on the front page of the New
York Times for a tiger week or something
there should be and everyone in the city
should know what is underneath the
ground in greenpoint who did it and when
and where
one thing i should say subjective we did
it it's very hard to say who did it
because Standard Oil one of the parties
responsible is no longer stand there
going also oil companies if you know
anything about the way they fracture and
so it's hard to figure out what identity
Standard Oil who's been inherited by so
Exxon was one of the parties held
responsible but there are many other oil
companies that were involved to this so
that's part of the frustration next we
really hear from Laura Hoffman and Laura
half Hoffman is a long time resident of
Greenpoint and her parents grew up there
she grew up there she has six children
moving up there and she will hear her
talk about her health but she's an
activist with a lot of health problems
and she actually organized something
called outrage which is stands for
united for trash reduction and garbage
faculty and she's a real community
activist and it was very instrumental in
connecting the project two narrators
people really trusted her my first
apartment was toward the corner of
McGinnis Boulevard near the bridge and
we had at we were on the ground floor
and we had access to the yard why use
that God and we cleaned it up
immaculately and you know we uncovered
what looked like flower beds for many
years ago and all of these like Louise
of the valley stuff that had declared
the dance started coming up again and we
had a wonderful vegetable garden you
know I made two pots of tomato sauce and
all kinds of stuff for my kids not
knowing what was in that soil we used to
get a lot of times in the morning there
was a funny ish on top of the tomatoes
and you know back then like I said was
dude my 20s that was kind of naive I
used to just take the hose right off we
picked the tomatoes crush them up made
the tomato sauce brown family a couple
of years later whether we had moved up
on the corner of the pond street
manhattan avenue i learned from being on
the fifth form and seeing the puffs of
smoke that that was actually incinerator
rash many years after that I learned
that that incinerator ash was packed
with dioxins and stuff that never leave
the soil you know in thinking back I was
serving my family loads of dioxin filled
tomatoes
these clips they're also over the years
even as a little girl I remember coming
home from upstate with my family and you
always knew when you were getting to
greenpoint even if he was sleeping in
the car the smell would just slap you in
the face as you were coming over the
greenpoint avenue bridge and I remember
my father always like put in his hand to
his chest and set and say ah put put a
tiger in your tank yeah well that that
was a slow but back then slogan for I
think the company's name was SL at the
time put a tiger in your tank so clearly
my father knew that Exxon thought were
as so oil in the in the creek so like
later one India's when I heard all of
this stuff people saying that that the
oil in the creek was rediscovered it
really pissed me off because there was
no rediscovered about it it's up it's
been there people have known Department
of Health who's known the EPA has known
de has known Dec has known so in my book
all of these agencies along with the
polluters or guilty of a really creating
a bad environmental situation not only
for the creek but for the the people who
lived along the creek as far as I'm
concerned they are in part responsible
for people's health problems over the
is including my family's her family
lived on one block some people argued
that it was not the block but that was
familial that it was genetic but the
thing is her family her husband and
people related just by marriage were
also experiencing rare diseases and her
dog too so it was clear to her she has
no question that something was going on
in her neighborhood next I'm just going
to play some audio this is the
narrator's name is Mildred hunt and she
and her husband were both
audio quality well I'm not sure about it
but I did wonder why i was diagnosed
with lupus fibromyalgia and this which
they called the seas of the young and I
don't know what I'm doing with it and my
next-door neighbor has a Parkinson's and
the lady directly across the street he
passed away of blue garrix then and the
lady wrote all this down the block she
got a rare blood disease came on
something they don't know what it was
and right here fuck that this will
happen recently now he's Lady Elizabeth
she had lupus and she wasn't young you
and the ground i told you about 44 year
old girl she didn't live here in Rhode
she got married and move but she did
grow up here and she died at 44 with
cancer they don't know they don't know
what the cancer came from that this all
happened just couple two years I me I
think that's too much warm water well I
didn't realize that that they had big
oil spill in the seventies and you know
that's that's what my kids were growing
up and everything I don't know not
matter I I thought it was something the
past but now now at the toll and my
husband said that when he was widened
their 1995 in that area they told him to
stay away from there that that hadn't
been properly no claim my pharmacist was
telling the other day that
they have been dumping chemicals but I
was not involved in the average this was
done both by Rachel and by a young
community member in Devon kodel locked
into a training session and never left
she really was responsible for a lot of
this project as well and I also had a
student who became the outreach intern
and she buy just the connections with
her family was responsible for getting a
whole cluster of mass Bethany rears
involved in the project because
someone asked ah ok so very briefly the
plan was to fly or three target
neighborhoods the three neighborhoods i
described set up a skype voicemail
service and create a designated email
address examples of successful outreach
efforts including included things like
emailing a pastor at a church and then
going to a service and introducing the
project going to a housing project and
speaking with the president of the
housing board then taking a follow-up
trip going to a nursing home speaking
during activities our holding
informational meetings at public
libraries and restaurants so I did go to
at least one of the public meetings
which was interesting and I'll talk
about that but you can hear how much
like work it takes and time you know
time it takes to convince people to let
me do that my work and less accessible
outreach efforts included attempting age
polish residence in greenpoint although
Yvonne used
translated all the media and all the
flyers and polish for the Polish weekly
and the polish radio show we did not get
polish narrators involved in the project
community board games also yielded no
results street festivals were not
successful rotary meetings in maspeth
not successful PTA meetings now
parochial schools and hit one persistent
effort the swinging 60s Seneca a female
bacliff that was ported because of
liability concerns so it's a Senior
Center and the center was worried about
having people on tape or the Internet so
a request to present was denied there
ultimately eight people signed up for a
training session held at the green note
citizens club and I included this
photograph just to show you this place
has not changed at all I wouldn't see
the inside has anyone been there so I
ran this session and the day began with
coffee and bagels and we went through
interview techniques technical tutorials
with equipment and then we followed this
with inner kid practice and trainees
receives a practice trip totally to
modify it once they all agreed on what
we were doing
and they also received a technical crib
sheet and a list of helpful hints or
things to do before during and after an
interview like remembering to check your
batteries remember to thank some on the
next day things like that so today when
Rachel and I discussed not today
recently when I stuff with Rachel this
whole trajectory of the project she
describes his training day as the high
point of the project it was a really
good feeling in the space and it felt
like a lot of momentum was being
generated also that was the day that is
on Codell a young resident in her 20s
joined as a paid staff member shortly
after the training and she ended up
playing a very instrumental role so now
I could give a sense of the plan for the
project and I'm going to tell you what
actually happened which is different
it's always different so in the end the
project is comprised of 21 narratives
instead of 50 that we hoped for and the
other major deviation from the project's
design that almost all of these
interviews were conducted by von poudel
who was a community member but she
hadn't of their 10 years and it's
deviated from the design
community-based project so we were based
in the community but it didn't sort of
follow the definition of what a
community-based project is where any
interviewer and interviewee vice versa
so most obvious problem the project was
just this discrepancy between designing
the realized project and then there was
some other pump is that really interest
me and still interested me so I just
want to share those with you so one
meeting I attended at the Greenpoint
public library it was packed with local
residents this was also another early
sign that people were really excited and
angry and just that they were going to
be involved and this is where I first
observed some problems so several
residents feared that the negative that
the neighborhood would be negatively
portrayed in this kind of project and I
think this is a very valid concern they
were worried that their property values
will go down some of the conservative
residents didn't believe there was a
connection between the environmental
issues in the neighborhood
and people's health problems and so they
didn't want this narrative to be
disseminated some residents did believe
that there was a connection but they
felt they be further victimized if their
property was devalued with the
possibility of no game for them they
didn't think we were in a position to
offer remediation even if indirectly
that's what we hope for so it was
interesting because i'd say this group
also didn't necessarily value the
narrative approach as effective in terms
of policy or change which is up there
you know it's okay to be suspect of this
approach and that's one thing you're
dealing with if you're using this
approach people don't see it as a direct
sort of they don't necessarily see it as
a means to an end so they have to be
engaged in the process even though you
can't necessarily promise something like
remediation okay and then one unexpected
problem occurred at the training session
so this session that I mentioned we
gathered eight people were sitting
eating bagels we're talking about we're
getting ready to practice interviewing
each other and I was talking about
open-ended questions and how we let's
see I guess the example was
do you see any connection between your
neighborhood and your health that was
the question you were practicing with
and Laura ha you heard from her she was
at the training session as was her
husband and both the Hoffmans are
longtime residents and their in their
50s and when I would I pose this
question do you see any connection
between your neighborhood in your health
I'll never forget this mr. Kaufman
exploded oh I know what the problem is
and I'm going to tell them he had very
strong thoughts and feelings and he was
ready to tell his story but he wanted to
be an interview or two so um this was a
really interesting problem because I
don't think I anticipated at least maybe
Rachel Michael did that we'd be into
negotiating the pain of participants at
the training session that we would
really be dealing with their pain that
day we thought we were all rolling up
our sleeves and this unique relationship
with being insider interviewer brings
special problems so I wonder and how
could we ask the Hoffmans to suppress
their knowledge of what was going on in
the community which was accumulated from
years of personal experience and refuted
by all of these so-called experts at
their neighborhoods so at this point it
felt that all the Hoffmans had was there
certitude to keep them from going insane
and we were basically asking them to
stain a particular brand of neutrality
and in essence we were temporarily
silent seeing the people we hope to get
releases so I thought that was a really
interesting problem in an unexpected
conflict so we open this up to the group
there were about 10 or 11 of us in the
room what do we do mr. Hoffman feels
really strongly he wants to tell up on
what the problem is but how are we going
to gather people's feelings about what
they think the problems are so we went
back and forth and we came up to a
particular solution or at least a
rationale to offer to discuss off tape
your thoughts and feelings after
generously listening to the interview
and that's kind of how we framed it that
was a generosity we were extending and
we proposed this with the idea that we
want to authentically record residents
own thoughts including this information
so we didn't want mr. Hoffman to correct
any one we wanted to collect
misinformation we wanted to collect this
moment in time what people thought was
happening even if the interviewer team
these narratives incorrect so mr.
Hoffman agreed reluctantly
not do any interviews that said both of
the Hoffmans stepped up to make many
introductions to interview me Hitler
problem fear the internet so the
Internet including habitat map didn't
really serve as an adequate form of
reciprocity for seniors I'm not saying
that all all seniors don't use the
internet my sister's here and our
grandmother learn to email and so it can
be maybe some people are very
comfortable with the internet but it
shouldn't be assumed that they are and
also the internet really scared older
residents in terms of their private
information they some others didn't know
how to work and what it meant so this
was particularly an issue that's waiting
60 center as i mentioned journalists
looking for interviewees after listening
to their bikes so Rachel was founded by
journalists after that math was released
I'm going to talk about the timing there
was some attention and buzz
about the map and the project and after
hearing these they're dudes then it was
like handy journalist accidentally the
people or their clothes for their
articles and then they wanted to find
these people and we hadn't really
thought about that with the narrator's
like you might be bothered a lot now
journalists might call you a lot do you
want to be a spokesperson and so they
haven't agreed to that and journalists
were constantly calling Rachel and she
would was having to vet the journalists
that basically is a good person or a bad
person and then decide you know it was
just a very extended process but we have
a solution for this which i will share
I'm going to talk about solutions to you
now just problem and then legal issues
so regarding the lawsuits i mentioned
that were in motion so this was
something that i'd say i decided it
wasn't an issue i don't think we had
recognizes an issue and about a week or
two before we were supposed to start the
interviews I thought wait a second what
about those lawsuits you know I'm
thinking about the nature of narrative I
just hated the idea that we could be
under
Mining someone's testimony in court if
they tell us one thing on tape and say
another thing in court and as oral
historians we know this happens and we
don't think that's shifty or strange we
know that different interviewers elicit
different answer so we can account for
the contradiction what where's mom shall
we take Morgan front row so they are not
may be interested in this gray area so I
thought we really don't want to
publicity narratives that could be
subpoenaed and somehow and of harming
our narrators so I couldn't really get
answers about how the narratives might
affect those involved in the class
action lawsuit partly because I realized
it was a problem very late in the game
so one solution is to take caree early
about this um but I felt I couldn't get
anyone interested in the problem that's
another problem so I was asking people
about it and so this brought up this
interesting thing that I've seen in oral
history as a field and I definitely see
in academia which is this double
standard of what we're doing that were
very effective but we're also harmless
and it doesn't really make sense it's
kind of so I found these ideas to be
contradictory it was like a statement
about our own disbelief that these would
ever actually reach a wide audience or
that we would have an impact so I think
we can't be sloppy and default to a
defensive irrelevance or security and so
I have some thought to make it to the
solution part lastly Public Health
reports so the project was such a labor
of love especially for Rachel who spent
so much time on it she was a master
student this was not for school and she
was working full-time so this was above
beyond school and her work and the
project took so much longer than she
thought it would that she started her
doctoral program whether China she was
wrapping this project up and the idea
was at this public health report because
782 agencies politicians we had a long
list and the public house report came
out and then it was a whole other job to
disseminate it so after it was said to
the obvious politicians and the obvious
community members then it was just
sitting in her house
it's so depressing to think about
actually I didn't get to Brooklyn save
us hooking you bring them with me
because we want these to be out but it
sounds so easy but you don't hand them
out like you know it's you can't just
like hand them out like like a free
yogurt sample on the street you know if
you want to be a little bit thinking
about who would be interested in this so
the public health reports of sitting
Eric's any of you are interested in them
maybe I could get some left to Columbia
or some other central locations and
original would be thrilled okay the last
problem or we got two solutions and
recommendations the last problem is
something that Rachel and I are still
figuring out which is our position
relative to the subject of the
neighborhood so I mentioned Rachel hi
both live in the neighborhood and
Michael I'm binder has been very active
in the Newtown Creek Alliance but
doesn't live in the neighborhood but the
stories told even at the informational
meetings really upset people Laura
Hoffman extremely articulate narrator
and her story is devastating and I do
have a student
you didn't continue with the project
after going to one of those idiots she
went home and soft and she lives in the
neighborhood and really it was hard to
deal with and Rachel and I had an
interesting conversation at the
project's end about how we dealt with it
which was basically remembering and
forgetting and this is something that
probably people who live in the area do
and and so I wanted to ask Rachel about
her position relative to this projects
this is an interview I did with her not
as far as a project as part of my
thinking about the project I don't think
I allow myself to think about it very
much the only time is when it hits me in
the face which is on particular
intersection walking back from the
subway to my new apartment on Manhattan
nice bloomsburg and this one
intersection there's the worst smell and
it's not necessarily sewer but it's
sewer mixed with something else and it's
really bad particularly in the summer
and every time I smell it I'm like kind
of kind of makes me think there's
something going on but then I walk away
and my block smells great so I I'm okay
with that again and I don't have that
it's a residential area i'm not near the
industrial zones so i feel that where I
live is ok as an outsider it gives you I
mean I was on both an outsider in an
insider that's what it is so I'm an
outsider because I'm a newcomer so I
don't know the history and I was very
interested in learning about that but
I'm an insider in the sense that I live
here now and owned property here and I'm
invested in living in this neighborhood
for conceivably a long time no cuz I've
been thought enough about that but I
think it added both good and bad
elements but probably would have been a
different project had I not been a
resident here or been a long-term
resident here perhaps I wouldn't even
want it to do the project if I was a
long-term resident I don't know but
because it was so new and I hadn't heard
any
about it that that was really those
striking and I thought that issue more
information should come to the surface
and who better to learn it from then
gives residents who have been here their
whole lives so I think it was a bit of a
knowledge quest a personal knowledge
quest in addition to one for the
community so when I got together with
Rachel to debrief about the project
keith black green point she'd been
living on one of the plumes she had
moved his feelings hurt one of the
others became her hood that's affected
by Newtown Creek in the surrounding
environmental burden so she electively
as a property owner bought something in
East Williamsburg and she was four
months pregnant when we did this
interview so asked about her hold off on
that you know as a brief confessional I
could have been interviewed for this
project I fit the criteria unlike Rachel
because i did in the neighborhood for
more than 10
at the time of this project and yet I
really didn't want to make connections
between my health problems at the toxins
and I do have an autoimmune disorder
that was under control at the time that
we were doing these interviews and I
didn't think it would be empowering or
cathartic for me to speak about this and
my questions I had about possible
connection I felt it would increase my
anxiety so I was helping to aggregate
this broader sample but I fail to see my
own input as valuable contribution in
fact I was kind of worried I would
destroy the narrative because I thought
I bless sure the connection between my
health issues and where I lived all
these years and I thought people the
stories I was hearing people who are
very sure and very clear and at the same
time I appreciate that people who are
willing to make these connections you
know because given all of my denial
Rachel's now it's very scary to even
think about this it's very scary to
think that your environment has
view and it leads to a lot of feelings
of helpless as it can so to some degree
the project regulated our anxiety I
think and our previous sense of
helplessness looking back I think I
should have participated as an
interviewee if only to throw in with the
interviewees and Rachel and I discussed
by us and neutrality and the fact that
we all feed all three of us that there
was definitely something going on and
that the problems were definitely
causing the health problem so how did
that affect the introduced in the winky
through the project I definitely had an
opinion on all these matters I was my
undergrad was an environmental health so
I had studied environmental justice and
toxic pollutants and all that stuff and
I knew there's a lot going on and
there's a power dynamic in the
neighborhood with the experts in the
state regulatory and City regulatory
agencies versus the community members
you know the lay people and so I
definitely had a bit of an agenda and
that's going to show through I'm sure
how can that not impact a project but at
the same time trying to understand more
about the context of the community and
not just the problems in the community
was a way I think of getting a more
holistic picture so okay
to get solutions or recommendations so
for those of you who are looking to use
this as a model or just use oral history
in a public health context I hope that
some of these recommendations and our
wistful you know things we wish we had
done will be helpful to you okay so
conducting a needs assessment early on
in the process this was Rachel's idea
that she thinks looking back that even
signing contracts with community
partners would be a good idea so we can
find out very early on how can you help
with this project how many hours do you
have what kind of jobs would you be
interested in taking on and this was
especially issue when it came time to
disseminating the reports it had been
very ambiguous who was going to do that
so Rachel thought Newtown Creek Alliance
was going to do that they didn't think
they were going to do that so who is
going to help you to what what is
available to you the timing of the
training is important so if we conducted
the training later people were ready to
go after the training I feel like they
had an interview scheduled two days
later the project would have gone off
with its original design but if you have
a recorder it never used before
supporter and if you've never come for
do anything before and then someone
calls you six weeks later
interview you don't even have the
equipment in your home it's very
intimidating and so I think the training
should have been done closer to the time
of the schedule interviews what if the
project was evolving so much as we're
figuring out who was our research team
and would they buy in and then once they
body and we'll through our interviewees
but they should have interviewed each
other like the next day so I recommend
that you tie your training is very close
to the time of your introduce the
journalist problem so this seems really
easy to solve now I should identify
people early we're willing to be media
contacts and that can even be on the
release form so or it can be asked after
it could be a separate release form but
identifying people ahead of time and
what someone calls you i'm sorry that
person is not interested in being a
media contact outreach so are we should
be a sign of most time every budget it's
just it's the foundation of your project
and it's more important to complicate
people who have door shut in their faces
and people who added audio purely
because of the risk involved so next
stopping to reflect on successes and if
you re work your project design you
might think you're doing this if for
those of you involved in projects but
you might not be because I think that
some conversations you talk about stuff
that's going well and stuff that's not
going well but often the conversation
turns to stuff it's not going well
setting aside a separate conversation we
only talk about what's going well it's
not just a morale boost which it is but
it also helps you place the project
strength which you're burying by always
talking about problems so what are the
strengths what is going well and how can
we expand that how can we play to our
projects as it organically changes
lastly legal so we decided not to
interview anyone involved in class
action lawsuit because we could not get
satisfactory answers and I wasn't
satisfied with the solution because I
thought it was the best one given that
we couldn't get answers but more
recently an environmental lawyer at the
Newtown Creek Alliance let me know that
law firms are interested in pro bono
work especially just kindly they won't
have to go to court and she felt that
counseling on these kinds of issues
might be appealing to them so she
promised to put me in touch with a few
people so knowing that's a possibility
might help you
okay so outcomes of the project both of
math and the report were made available
in September 2010 which was tied to be
released simultaneously coincide with
the announcement that Newtown Creek was
finally designated a superb website so
once that happened people were suddenly
researching me Tom preos and your times
it was it was everywhere so the idea was
that it would generate some buzz and
people would find this map on the
particular group of narratives were
given the name quick speed because we
had to name our map on how the top hat
and a logo was designed two months later
two of the lawsuits were settled and the
last time you the third was pending and
discovery so a lot happens in three
months after years of spaces so for me
the project is an example of
investigators working across several
fields and bringing together the
language method and resources a fair
fields and including this emergent
possibility of mapping which i think is
of increasing interest oral historians
and ritual goal was to galvanize III
disparate communities by having them
interview one another but although that
wasn't accomplished in that form I do
think that makes Williamsburg in maspeth
are now included in the wider
conversation about creek and about
environmental hazard so I do feel that
you were able to expand or map a little
and change the dialogue because people
typically talk about Greenpoint
greenpoint great one okay so I want to
wrap up by just talking about questions
i'm left with which i really i help a
way to start our conversation so these
are questions i'm left with I don't have
the answers so when you're starting a
community conversation how can you build
a flexible project so it can continue to
grow without its original leadership so
by the time Rachel needs to move on or I
need to move on how what if people that
still want to talk what does they call
next week who is there to listen to them
to add my choices to the project so
building in a starting a project is I
away sort of a transmission of this
project to another person and community
proof is important I think for if you I
think it's important so what kinds of
compromises are okay strike when you and
your project partners from other fields
have different best practices so for
example I don't use a script ever when
I'm interviewing in doing a strictly
oral history interview but this one
through an IRB at Hunter and Rachel head
and hand them scripts and the script had
to be approved so what do you do when
you're each adhering to your best
practices but they don't overlap
perfectly and that's been a really
interesting challenge as I continue to
work with other kinds of organizations
witches institutions whether its museums
or a project like this so this is
something that comes up a lot as an oral
historian how can you serve project
partner but not feel like a house guest
in someone else's home get embedded in
another field or institution so or
ministries sometimes considered a subset
of a project because it's a methodology
people don't realize it's a field and
oral histories considered a means to an
end so it kind of gets old and sometimes
if you're working with project partners
in safe public health you know you're a
helping hand but how can you assert oral
history values and oral history
characteristics and earlier tonight the
students who were talking about the
ethical practices oral
we held an interview these other fields
with more ethical considerations so
lastly this isn't on a slide how can we
be protected without being so cautious
that we eliminate the risk but also the
game so those of you who are working on
difficult projects with either unloved
narrators or areas who people think it's
unethical to interview this question is
really important so of course we want to
do no harm but we also don't ignore
entire populations because it's hard to
figure out how to interview them I
especially children and minors I think
it's yes there are complicated issues
but we need to hear from people under 18
right so a lot of people this is
something I'm really interested in how
can we be protected without being too
cautious and kind of silencing entire
groups of people so I'm going to stop